auf dem weg ins wochenende sind sie hier
genau richtig für halle deutschland
herzlich willkommen in unserem kader
kompakt schauen wir heute auf einem der
äußerst gut besuchten wertstoffhöfe
vorbei es geht in einer hausarztpraxis
dann ist ja auch gerade so einiges
anders
außerdem beantwortet die virologin frau
professor ulrike protzer hier später
ihre zuschauer fragen
los geht's mit dem läuft von heute und
einem protest der besonderen art das
mittagessen könnte so schön sein an
diesem sonnigen tag heute in dresden vor
der frauenkirche
doch diese tafel ist protest
chursächsische gastronomen und
eventmanager sehen ihre existenz
gefährdet deshalb haben sie über 100
leere stühle auf dem neumarkt
aufgestellt sie wollen eine perspektive
für die wiedereröffnung ausgerechnet ein
taucher treff im niedersächsischen
oldenburg hat jetzt zu viele
schutzmasken
der laden ist zu deshalb werden sie
hinterm haus verteilt der chef hat sie
eher aus versehen geordert als ich nun
überhaupt nicht wusste was wir die zeit
machen sollen
schickte mir ein chinesischer lieferant
bei dem wir sonst unsere stand up
paddling boards beziehen ihre
informationen dass er auch
atemschutzmasken liefern kann also nur
damit der container voll wurde bestellte
er massig masken made in china
noch bevor das schiff überhaupt in
deutschland anlegte machte die meldung
von neuen masken die runde
danach habe ich 14 tage lang keine
ruhige minute wäre ja da ist inzwischen
eine aktion rausgekommen mit über
220.000 atemschutzmasken die jetzt noch
im zulauf zu uns sind die ersten 20.000
sind gestern gekommen und wir fangen
gerade an hier die auszugeben
jetzt verteilt der taucher treff seine
chinesischen masken an arztpraxen ärzte
pflegedienste aber auch an
privatpersonen oldenburg hat neue corona
helden martin schliff ski und seine
mitarbeiter nick delhi sio kann den
leuten so nahe kommen wie er will mit
seiner quarantäne kugel rollt der
amerikanische künstler tag für tag durch
seine wahlheimat stuttgart und
begeistert damit viele schwaben
[Applaus]
die zahl der nachgewiesenen infizierten
liegt in deutschland heute stand 16 uhr
30 laut hopkins universität bei rund
138.000 rund 81.000 800 menschen sind
genesen 4105 infizierte sind gestorben
die gute nachricht die reproduktionsrate
der infizierten liegt bei nun 0,7 das
heißt dass inzwischen im durchschnitt
momentan aktuell nicht mehr jede person
eine andere person an steckt also jede
person die infiziert ist eine andere
person ansteckt wir haben es geschafft
das dynamische wachstum zurückzubringen
zu einem linearen wachstum der ausbruch
ist stand heute wieder beherrschbaren
beherrschbarer geworden berlin geht also
mit zuversicht ins wochenende und auf
dem weg dahin freue ich mich auf unsere
heutige corona kompakt experten auch
frau professor ulrike protzer sie ist
die direktorin des instituts für
virologie an der technischen uni in
münchen herzlich willkommen
wir haben ja gerade gehört erstaunlich
gute nachrichten in diesen tagen in
bezug auf die ansteckungsrate liegt bei
0,7 also unter der wichtigen 1 wie es
immer heißt und hieß was genau bedeutet
das aber eigentlich und wie kommt man
auf diese zahl
letztendlich stellt man immer fest
wieviel im durchschnitt natürlich wie
viele neue menschen kann jemand der die
infektion hat anstecken und am anfang
waren wir drei zahlen von 2,3 bis 2,7
das heißt ein infizierter hat 23 bis 27
zwei bis drei neue menschen angesteckt
und das ist inzwischen durch die kontakt
beschränkungen deutlich zurückgegangen
das war das was wir wollten
weil wir dieses exponentielle dynamische
wachstum einfach stoppen wollten
und da sind wir jetzt durch die
maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben
da sind wir hingekommen frage ist
natürlich was passiert wenn wir die
maßnahmen wieder lockern
das kann keiner sagen aber wir können
weitere fragen klären und zwar mit ihnen
gleich wir kommen später nämlich nochmal
zurück nach münchen
damit den fragen unserer zuschauer also
ist gleich während der vielen langen
corona tage und wochen zu hause die zu
eben diesem erfolg ist ja geführt haben
da ist man zwangsläufig immer wieder bei
den drei großen
gelandet kg auf dem sofa herum hängen
aber wie alles im fernsehen gucken was
kommt und ein weiteres a aufräumen und
ausmisten viele machen das seit
ewigkeiten wieder zum ersten mal ja und
entsprechend voll ist es deshalb an den
wertstoffhöfen ein ganzer kofferraum
voller kartonagen es sind die überreste
der pakete die bahn rechte in online
shops bestellt hat viele läden hatten ja
zu deshalb hat er alles was er braucht
im netz geordert und auch manches was er
sonst vielleicht nicht unbedingt gekauft
hätte man nimmt sie schon mehr zeit für
für sachen die man sonst nicht gemacht
hat
man fängt an irgendwelche sachen zu
bestellen die man keine ahnung der
irgendwann mal aufgefallen sind wo man
aber keine zeit mehr hatte und das macht
man eben jetzt dann auch natalie ist
heute auf den wertstoffhof nach
böblingen gefahren und auch bei ihm ist
vieles zusammengekommen
in letzter zeit vor allem plastikabfälle
firma ist zu wissen sie also bleiben wir
zu hause
es laufe so wie er machen das im moment
deutschlandweit offenbar viele der
ansturm auf die wertstoffhöfe die
geöffnet haben riesig stau auch hier in
böblingen
zum einen weil eben mehr menschen zum
müll abladen kommen als sonst zum
anderen weil sie hier immer nur zehn
leute gleichzeitig auf den hof lassen
warten ist also angesagt
um den ansturm hier zumindest
einzubremsen appellieren die betreiber
inzwischen nur dann zu kommen wenn es
unbedingt nötig ist und wir haben jetzt
eingeschränkt das thema renovierungs
abfälle
da sind wir der meinung die können auch
mal vielleicht noch zwei drei wochen in
der garage oder im keller liegen bleiben
auf dem hof gilt außerdem die regel zwei
meter mindestabstand einhalten
die meisten haben verständnis dafür und
halten sich daran
selbstverständlich gesundheit geht vor
und respekt vor anderen leuten auch den
anderen ihr abstand halten
ob es eine zeit lassen keine hektik ich
waren letzte woche hat es noch nicht so
jetzt habe ich mich schon gewundert dass
man da in der reihe hier mit dem auto
anstehen muss ja aber so gehen sie ja
natürlich
wir machen alles mit was zur gesundheit
dient ja dass die regeln auch von allen
eingehalten werden darauf achten die
mitarbeiter wie liter city zum schutz
aller wir gucken auf unsere gesundheit
klar unter anderen muss ja sein und
halten einen gewissen abstand ein und
gibt es auch menschen die sich über die
massnahmen beschweren
ja das gibt's natürlich und ja wir
regeln das dann und erklären szene dann
und versuchen den hell vielleicht auch
mit einer gewissen abstand auch trotzdem
zu helfen nicht überall in deutschland
sind die wertstoffhöfe im moment
geöffnet
die entscheidung ob auf oder zu trifft
in der regel die kommune vor ort
abhängig unter anderem vom platzangebot
auf den höfen sagt der verbandsvize
[Musik]
denn die hat priorität auch zum
gesundheitsschutz der bevölkerung
im landkreis böblingen sind sie froh
dass sie die ganze zeit über alle
wertstoffhöfe offen halten konnten
die aktuelle lage im land ist aber
natürlich trotzdem immer ein thema
nicht nur bei der arbeit ganz klar aber
ich glaube es geht anderen menschen
genauso und ich glaub mir sachen des
alle zusammen mit abstand halten und
rücksicht nehmen
auch auf dem wertstoffhof oder aber auch
in der praxis des eigenen haus arztes
denn corona virus in pandemie her
all die anderen zu behandelnden
krankheiten die hören ja nicht plötzlich
auf
doch kann ich in diesen tagen überhaupt
guten gewissens zum arzt gehen worauf
sollte ich achten
ja und wie sorgt das praxisteam
eigentlich für die eigene sicherheit
praxis dr
hallo was haben sie denn für symptome
vieles hat sich hier verändert seit
beginn der pandemie wie sieht er aus der
neue praxisalltag in zeiten der korona
krise mit welchen neuen
herausforderungen sind arzt und
patienten konfrontiert
es ist mittwochmorgen also heute sie ist
nicht so viel los in der sprechstunde
die meisten patienten bleiben halt
lieber zu hause weil sie angst haben
dass ich den schirm in corona virus
anstecken
sie rufen dann eher an und deswegen so
oft das telefon bei uns die
risikopatienten bleiben lieber zu hause
im praxisbetrieb hat sich inzwischen
eine gewisse routine eingestellt wenn
auch teilweise unter veränderten
vorzeichen schülern ihre beschwerden
[Musik]
hatten sie kontakt zu jemand der positiv
getestet ist
so war mal probieren aber ich bin halt
gucken kann
weil die zunge raus und jetzt im haus
dann kommt etwas in den nacken legen ja
privat zu privat hat geklappt nicht
optimal aber ich sehe ich schon also
schlimmer sagen würde ich ihn katharina
würde ich einfach sagen ich schreibe
ihnen eine krankmeldung sie bleiben
jetzt einfach mal den rest der woche zu
hause ja und wenn es nicht besser wird
rufen sie mich noch mal an
beziehungsweise wir können ihnen einen
termin geben der praxis dass ich nicht
erwartet zumal anstecken
doch die meisten patienten kommen
weiterhin persönlich in oder genauer
gesagt zunächst vor die praxis um so ein
mögliches ansteckungsrisiko zu
verringern
also die patienten werden erstmal auf
die behandlungs zimmer verteilt da war
ja einige wartezimmer nicht zu viele
patienten dar einsetzen
wir haben höchstens drei mit großem
abstand und der rest bleibt draußen ist
wenn immer nur so die patienten
reingerufen dass wir sie auch verteilen
können das nicht die gefahr besteht dass
sich untereinander anstecken ich hätte
ihr rezept
machen sie zum bleiben gezwungen also
wenn jetzt welche anrufen und sagen sie
haben fieber und sie möchten ein
abstrich gemacht bekommen die kommen
dann in die praxis werden so fortgesetzt
der abschluss splittern gemacht und die
patienten verlassen dann daraufhin
sofort die praxis gehen wieder nach
hause und müssen dann so lange unter
quarantäne bleiben bis der abstrich
wieder daraus ein zimmer weiter muss
eine blinddarm patienten versorgt werden
die operation war vor einer woche er hat
sohn sebastian ebenfalls mediziner
kümmert sich um sie die fäden müsse nun
dringend gezogen werden ein
routine-eingriff für den trotz corona
chaos zeit sein muss es ist ein bisschen
umständlicher geworden
das ist nicht geringer geworden es war
die erste phase die ersten wochen war es
doch ein kleiner hand sturm den wir den
wir zu bewerkstelligen hatten aber
mittlerweile hat das abgelagertes macht
nachgelassen das müssen abgeflaut und
die menschen halten sie einfach nicht
folgen kann ist klar
der betrieb geht ganz normal weiter
krone macht nicht halt vor fußpilz
kinder entzündung durchfall
halsschmerzen und leichte erkältung doch
immer wieder die sorge wegen corona
rowohlt haben sie fieber dann kommen sie
heute nachmittag wenn keine patienten in
der praxis sind glücklicherweise
verläuft die pandemie hier bisher in
überschaubaren grenzen
wir hatten schon viele verdachtsfälle
holen wirklich gedacht haben okay da von
corona wie hausarbeit es hat sich halt
in den in allen fällen hat es nicht
verstehen
nun stehen noch die täglichen
hausbesuche an die finden zum teil in
ganzkörper schutzanzügen stadt denn
viele der patienten sind besonders
infektionsgefährdet und von dort aus der
hausarztpraxis zur direktorin des
instituts für virologie der tu münchen
zu frau professor dr ulrike protzer
zurück zu ihnen herzlich willkommen
nochmal schleswig holstein hat gesagt
dass man großveranstaltung mit bis zu
1000 teilnehmern stufenweise wieder zu
lassen möchte ist das nicht ein risiko
sicherlich ist ein risiko bei
großveranstaltungen da das hängt von der
veranstaltung an sich ab wie groß das
risiko ist wenn ich irgendwo sitze aber
was man immer mit bedenken muss diese
vielen menschen müssen dahin kommen zur
veranstaltung dazu brauchen sie häufig
öffentliche verkehrsmittel da kann es
dann zu eng werden
und auch in den eingängen und ausgängen
kann es sehr eng werden
das heißt da muss man dann sicherlich
dafür sorgen dass man entsprechend
abstand halten kann
vielleicht an mund nasen schutz tragen
ansonsten besteht das schon ein risiko
also keine entwarnung leider aber das
wird noch ein bisschen länger so bleiben
eine weitere frage die uns erreicht hat
man hört immer wieder von arzneimitteln
wir mdb oder chloroquin fragt jemand
anonymous welche erfahrungen hat man
denn inzwischen damit gemacht für das
rem diese wir seien mittel was direkt
das virus an greift also an seiner
vermehrung hindert und da gibt es eine
erste studie die jetzt publiziert wurde
die eigentlich schon viel versprechende
ergebnisse zeigt eine richtig
kontrollierte studie ist noch nicht
bekannt so dass das noch mal bewiesen
werden muss aber es sieht ganz gut aus
beim chloroquin was ja auch der
amerikanische präsident sehr befürwortet
hat ist das eher zurückhaltend auch da
gibt es erste publizierte daten die
sehen nicht so gut aus weil das mittel
einfach hohe nebenwirkungen hat weil es
nicht dass wir uns selber trifft sondern
die infizierten zellen versucht zu
treffen
und da muss man einfach immer mit mehr
nebenwirkungen rechnen von bereits
genesen personen können ja durch eine
blutspende antikörper gewonnen werden
schreibt karin mattick dadurch kann der
krankheitsverlauf positiv beeinflusst
werden
wie viele solcher antikörper können denn
von einer blut spenden etwa gewonnen
werden und wie viele menschen können
damit behandelt werden
das hängt natürlich sehr davon ab wieder
wie wir sagen antikörpertiter einer
person ist der kann niedrig sein wenn
die infektion noch nicht so lange her
ist das kann schon ein bisschen höher
sein
und das ist eine interessante methode
aber so wahnsinnig viele patienten aus
einer blutspende kann ich mich behandeln
und ich kann das ganze heute auch mit
skalieren
das heißt ich muss dann doch sehr viele
blutspender gewinnen um eine
ausreichende anzahl patienten behandeln
zu können
insofern ist es interessant aber nichts
was man jetzt in großen mengen anwenden
kann aber auch noch mal ein thema für
die nächste frage von egon teschner das
thema blut energie in verschiedenen
blutgruppen unterschiedlich auf das
corona wäre es gibt es blutgruppen die
im mond sind und welche die besonders
anfällig sind
da gibt es bisher keinerlei hinweise
dass das irgendetwas mit der blutgruppe
zu tun hätte es gibt schon hinweise dass
es erbliche faktoren gibt die kennen wir
aber noch nicht da braucht's forschung
das muss man untersuchen bei patienten
die einen leichteren verlauf haben bei
patienten die an schwerem verlauf haben
aber mit der blutgruppe soweit wir
wissen hat es nichts zu tun
eine frage die wir schon öfter hatten
aber die noch mal bestätigt werden soll
von gunnar erik rand der fragt nämlich
wäre einmal eine infektion überstanden
hat gilt als immun jetzt ihre antwort
ist das tatsächlich so fragte das ist
gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten
wir wissen von den ja normalen
coronaviren die es ja bei
erkältungskrankheiten gibt dass es eine
gewisse immunität gibt die scheint mich
wahnsinnig lange anzuhalten aber die
scheint schon wenige jahre anzuhalten
ob das gleiche für das neue virus
zutrifft wissen wir nicht wir wissen
gegen das sars corona virus von vor 17
jahren gibt es diese schützende
immunität aus studien an rhesusaffen
sieht es auch so aus also wir nehmen's
mal an aber 100 prozent gesichert ist es
nicht vielen dank dass die schwere
antworten leicht verständlich gemacht
haben vielen dank frau professor %
münchen und ihnen und ihrem team schon
mal vorab ein schönes wochenende an dem
sie dann liebe zuschauer auch gerne noch
mal weitere grüner kompakt ausgaben
schauen können die sind nämlich auch
alle auf youtube zu finden und zwar
kanal der zdf heute und hier im zdf
sehen sie später dann auch noch mal ein
spezial zur krone krise darin geht es um
die risiken der lockerungen um 58 geht
es los